even if you end up losing that b-pawn
you don't want to let black get the king
to d6 and fully
fully uh come together shout out to ben
dover
who just subscribed on our twitch
channel
if you can keep that king on e3 i'd
really do like white's prospects
uh no god please no
i like i like jenna tools thank you for
subscribing
back to the american obviously magnus
carlson still holds a sixth game leading
the match and uh he's back
back to his old tricks here and the kind
of position we expect if we're looking
for a slow grind
usually magnus carlsen is is controlling
the tempo of that grind
uh thank you to mike at old reese five
five for subscribing to our channel
appreciate the love and
and that's a pawn on d5 candy belongs to
seymour butts see more butts
see more butts who see more butts who
see more butts
nobody see more butts than you uncle
tony
[Applause]